hey guys it's dr. Berg here in this
video I want to talk about the problems
with kale now as you probably have
already seen a lot of my videos on
promoting kale because kale is amazing
it's anti-cancer anti-estrogen ik it
cleans up the liver it fixes the body
it's loaded with so many nutrients
vitamin A but it has a couple problems
okay for some people not for everyone
okay because a lot of times people it's
convenient you take this you blend it
you drink it and you're good for the day
so number one it can deplete iodine
alright but this really happens in
people with more hypothyroid problems
it's a real simple solution just add
seek help boom problem solved okay so
that's not a hard thing to do but number
two this is the big problem see your
microbes eat fiber you have 4 to 5
pounds of microbes in your gut that live
on fiber ok
adding kale in a blender for some people
can overload the microbes to the point
where you get constipation or bloating
if this happens
switch it up go to spinach you know
steam it cook it eat other vegetables
have salads instead but don't keep going
because if you're constipated if you're
bloated with too much fiber you're not
going to lose weight it's not going to
help you you're going to feel you're not
going to sleep that well so that's one
of the problems this fiber is kind of a
new thing for a lot of people they're
not used to digesting it so anything
that is a sudden change all of a sudden
you're drinking 20 cups of kale shake a
day that's might be too much for people
so I always suggest go small just start
with 1 and gradually increase it because
you're microbes will adapt over a period
of time and I'm talking about not the
majority maybe 20% of the population
just can't digest kale for the rest of
us we can digest it fine and it goes
right in we can no problem at all
but if you get constipation or bloating
switch up your vegetables to spinach or
salad okay hope that helped I'll see you
in the next video